pour notre ami philippe de dieuleveult a
disparu au zaïre avec six autres
personnes
philippe de dieuleveult qui n'a jamais
hésité à prendre de gros risques dans la
chasse aux trésors participé à une
expédition sur le fleuve zaïre fleuve
dangereux à cause des cascades
nombreuses et des chutes
l'équipe avait une liaison radio
quotidienne avec la france mais elle n'a
donné aucune nouvelle depuis 48 heures
roland sicard j'abuse mais lui ne s'est
pas trop libre je suis une autre pièce
il ya un piano il ya une petite cheminée
de ça peut être là ça c'est en principe
la radio depuis le succès de la chasse
au trésor les téléspectateurs
connaissent bien
philippe de dieuleveult le globe-trotter
d'antenne 2 ici à las vegas début
juillet il a entrepris une nouvelle
expédition une première descendre le
zaïre le plus long fleuve africain après
le nil sur un nouveau modèle de radeaux
pneumatiques
mais depuis mercredi on est sans
nouvelles de lui et de six de ses
compagnons l'armée zaïroise a entrepris
des recherches recherche rendue
difficile par le relief montagneux de la
région et son éloignement des grandes
villes à margut rno vous faisiez partie
de l'expédition vous êtes vous rentré 7
est une mission impossible dans ce padd
mission impossible c'était une mission
difficile mais c'était avant tout une
aventure donc un groupe de six à huit
personnes qui avaient décidé de vivre
cette aventure
moi je suis rentré pour des raisons
professionnelles le travail n'attend pas
et l'équipe a continué donc alors nous
avons une carte qui va nous aider à
mieux situer l'expédition à votre avis
où se trouve ce temps l'or actuellement
ils sont dans cette région là près de
matadi qui est le port sur l'embouchure
du fleuve zaïre à l'endroit où il se
jette dans l'atlantique et sont dans
cette région qui est extrêmement
montagneuse
il ya beaucoup de barrages beaucoup de
rapides beaucoup de chutes donc c'est un
coin très très délicat ici donc et la
région est donc très montagneuse très
difficile d'accès s'ils sont perdus
quelque part
ça va être assez dur de les localiser
car les moyens d'accès dans ce pays sont
très très difficile et retravaille
pourquoi ne donne-t-il aucune nouvelle
ça faisait chuter alors chaque bateau
est équipé d'une radio de faible
puissance ils ont abandonné à kinshasa
qui étaient ici donc un poste plus
grosse puissance qui nous permet d'être
qui nous permettait d'être en liaison
tous les jours avec paris c'est une
règle d'or dans l'équipe
tous les jours à 20 heures on avait une
raison précise vous êtes vous êtes parti
à la hauteur de kinshasa vous mais je
suis parti dans un peu plus haut une
première fois avec philippe qui est
reparti sur paris avec moi-même et
philippe est retourné à kinshasa pour
rattraper l'équipe et finir le petit
bout ici pour terminer donc l'expédition
et quand vous les avez quitté dans quel
état d'esprit était-il il savait où ils
servent que que la mission était de
bruit mais si vous voulez ce sont des
gens raisonnables
il y avait à bord un médecin et un
spécialiste mécanique spécialistes
transmission spécialistes navigation des
vivres de quoi boire de l'eau potable
fin aucun problème c'était une aventure
avec des dangers certes mais tout à fait
maîtrisable et les embarcations et est
si résistante
oui ils sont des prototypes des
cataractes des gros radeau pneumatique
mais huit mètres de long 3 m de large
une grosse structure métallique pour
couler ça il faut il faut vraiment un
très très gros accident
ce qui me fait penser qu'il n'y a pas de
choses trop grave c'est que nous avions
deux tonnes de matériel à bord dans des
emballages étanche et s'il y avait eu le
moindre incident on aurait retrouvé
quelque chose parce que ce matin à
l'orée flotter elle serait arrivée sur
l'atlantique
hélas là quelqu'un aurait trouvé quelque
chose c'est qu'une premiers ce serait
une première dans la totalité car nous
sommes partis de bujumbura qui est au
burundi nous avons descendu tout le lac
tanganika et traverser tout le flou
deuil et pourquoi cette expédition
l'aventuré aventures d'une bande de
jeunes qui qui en ont un peu marre de la
grisaille de paris merci l'aventuré
j'espère l'espoir un général avait
disparu il ya quelques années dans la
même région il a été retrouvée au bout
de trois jours